[Müzik]
her gün yeni bir şey çıkıyor
bu sözleri hepimiz annelerimizden
babalarımıza Büyüklerimizden duy
muşuz dedikleri doğru hep böyle
olacağını
[Müzik]
gelişmeye devam edin
burç
ilk olarak 1992 yılında yazılan
mezara evlerine dair yaygın farklıydı
ortaya çıktı
zaman zaman birbirinin yerine kullanılan
para meselelerle anlatmak büyük
bu paranın nelerden olan artırılmış
gerçeklik gerçek ortamda yapay bilgi
akışında gerçeklik algısının
yükseltilmesidir
basitleştirmem gerekirse gerçek ortamı
altyapı olarak kullanan yapay bilgi
platformudur
bir mobilya mağazasının
yeni bir kara peni müşterinin Oturma
odasında nasıl göreceğini göstermesi
Buna örnek olarak verilebilir
IKEA Amazon gibi markalarda çoktan bu
gerçekliği kullanmaya başladılar
2 numara sanal gerçekliği fiziksel
ortamın yanı sıra 3 boyutlu bir model
veya sanal ortamı kullanıcıya duygusal
ve psikolojik bir etki yaratması
dır Kısacası gerçek ortamda yapay
ortamın kurgulanmasıdır ve bir diğer
gözlüğü
gerekirse karma gerçeklik ise bu iki
gerçekliğin birleşimidir ve kullanıcı
hem gerçek nesnelerle hem de sanal
nesnelerle etkileşime girebiliyoruz
Ayrıca gerçek dünyanın bir görünümünü
tanımlar Real ve cihazları da bu
kategoriye girer
son ve 4 numaralı parametre yardımını
gerçeklik bir kişinin elleri serbest
olarak diğer yönü kontrol edebilmesine
kullanabilmesine izin veren herhangi bir
teknolojidir
yön bulma talimatlarında ön cam bir
araba veya başa takılabilir diyorsunuz
telgraf bu teknolojiye örnek verilebilir
yaşantımıza metabolizmayı pek çok kez
karşılaşıp farkına varamasak da
filmlerde hepimizin dikkatini çekmiştir
mesela hepimizin
Iron Man'in kostümünde de bu teknolojiyi
görebiliriz
metaforce'un eğitime sağladığı belli
başlı avantajlar deneyime dayalı eğitim
içeriye ve senaryoya bağlı
öğren elde edilen bilginin sahada
uygulanması ve deneme yanılma yöntemi
dir metavors eğitimde saatleri veya yeri
değil yetkinliği bildiren şeffaf
akridasyon primi uygulamak istiyorum Bu
Öğrencilerin öğrenme Teknik
lerine bireysel ihtiyaçlarına bakmanın
daha etkili
tüm Öğrencilerin farklı öğrendiğini ve
dolayısıyla farklı konsantrasyon
aralıklarına sahip olduğunu
ifade klasik bir sınıf ortamı herkes
için etkili değildir ve artan teknoloji
kullanımıyla bu özellikle daha az il
gi Aslında her şey eğitim sistemine
neden değiştir
memiz gerekiyor Bu değişim ihtiyacının
neyin tetiklediğine bakmak
la var kavidon 9 parmelisi eğitimde
sosyalleşmedeki düşüşü inkar edilemez en
büyük sebebidir
Karantina ve izolasyon dönemlerinin
getirdiği kısıtlamalarla bile eğitimde
yüksek düzeyde sosyalleşme sağlayabilir
sadece pratik uygulanabilir becerileri
değil aynı zamanda bunları sosyal bir
çevreye uygulamayı da öğren
ebileceğimiz form olabilir
meteorge Ayten teknoloji kullanımıyla
gelişim ve sanal gerçeklik aracılığıyla
dünyalar yaratır
sürükleyici özelliği sayesinde her
yaştan birçok öğrenciye hitap edecek ve
onlarla etkileşime geçecek
Peki Size bir soru sormak istiyorum
Sizce beyin ile görmek mümkün
meteorers bunu mümkün hale getiriyor
en iyi uygulamalarıyla gerçekleştir
elim beyin nörolojik açısından göz
fonksiyonlarını ortadan kaldırarak
direkt beyniyle görmeyi sağlayacak
aynı zamanda yatılılık hastaların
buzluğa gidememe durumunda da iş görecek
yazılı olarak hastalara Dünyanın her bir
tarafını görebilecekler
Tabi buna eğitimi uyarladığımızda da
birçok avantaj elde ederiz
engelli öğrencilere diğerleri ile eşit
şartlar sunulurken diğer öğrencilerinde
yetkinliği artacak
ne yazık ki Bir sınıfta herkesin tam
olarak eşit eğitim alması mümkün değil
günümüzde de artan umursamazlık ve
çekingenmek zorundayız sebebiyle geri
planda kalan öğrenciler
için ön plana çıkabilecek
düşündüğümüzde okul biraz daha
öğretmenler öğretsin ki platformun
altına karşın meteoroloji eğitimi
öğrenciler öğrencisi bile var
Sonuçta bir öğretmen ne kadar çok
öğretmek istese de anlamadığı bir konuyu
Anladım diyen öğrenci için yapabileceğim
bir şey kalmamış Halbuki bir makineyle
yalan söyleyemez
siniz demek istediğim meteoroloji sizin
söylediğiniz gibi gerçekten alabiliyoruz
Üstelik dijital dünyada varlıkların
maliyetleri düşünmektedir
Bu konudaki sorunların çözer
yeni bir okul Kampüsü tuğla ve harçlığı
somut olarak inşa etmek yerine
maliyetin sadece yüzde biri karşılığında
dişler dünyada inşa edilebilir
ya Buna örnek olarak geçen sene Düğün
maliyeti yüzünden evlenemeyen çiftlerin
haberlerinizi
Bu fiyatlar 2022'de daha da Art
tı ortalama 150.000 liraya 2000 yapmak
yerine 150 liralık bir internet
bağlantısıyla sizde meteorge devrinde
evlenebilirsiniz
Meta Word eğitiminde öğrenim kısmında
öğrenci yetiştirirken aktarın kısmında
sosyalleştirilir
kişiye göre ayar olabilen bir takım için
hem Mali açıdan hem de öznellik
açısından birçok avantaj
insan beyni Kısa vadeli eski
ci ama uzun vadeli etkileyi hafife alır
Ama siz Unutmayın ki meteorik kavramı
sayesinde biz yine Teknoloji ne kadar
çabuk
gelin her gün yeni bir şey çıkıyor
sözlerimizi tekrarlayacağız teşekkür
ederim
[Alkış]